the New York Times asks if Jared and
Ivanka are bad Jews Rolling Stone
wonders whether social justice can save
astrology and Democrats are undermining
election results oh it's a fantastic
Thanksgiving week i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show oh so much to
give thanks for our crazy political
system notwithstanding we're going to
talk about all of the crazy there's a
lot of crazy over the weekend because
every time i leave for the weekend
everyone tries to ruin it so well done
everyone but we survived and we'll
discuss all of it in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that
you've got credit card bills because the
fact is that if you have credit card
bills you didn't pay off that credit
card debt that stuff is racking up
interest charges at a rate you do not
even want to think about but you need to
think about it because if you don't
you're gonna be paying that stuff off
until you die with Lending Club however
you can consolidate your debt or pay off
credit cards with one fixed monthly
payment since 2007 Lending Club is how
millions of people regain control of
their finances with affordable
fixed-rate personal loans no trips to a
bank no high interest credit cards just
go to Lending Club com tell them about
yourself how much you want to borrow
pick the terms that are right for you
and if you're approved your loan is
automatically deposited into your bank
account in as little as a few days
Lending Club is the number one
peer-to-peer lending platform with over
thirty five billion dollars in loans
issued go to Lending Club comm slash Ben
check you're eight minutes bar up to
forty grand
that's Lending Club comm slash
Bennigan's Lending Club comm slash man
all loans made by web bank member FDIC
Equal Housing lender it's fantastic
service again you don't want to be
paying off credit cards until you die
and also if you just need a swing loan
because you're doing construction or
something Lending Club can help you I'll
go check them out right now Lending Club
comm slash Ben and check you're eight
minutes about up to forty grand
Lending Club comm /ban all right so we
begin today with the New York Times
doing what the New York Times does it
which is rip on Jews it doesn't like and
I say that advisedly the New York Times
is an awful awful newspaper an enormous
amounts of what the New York Times
covers with regards of the Jewish
community is basically the sub positions
of a bunch of Jews who don't care at all
about Judaism who don't care at all
about the Jewish religion and their
religion is leftism their religion is
Obama ISM and if you cross them then
they take this as an affront to their
Judaism the latest example of an article
like this is an article by Amy chose ik
and Hannah Seligson over the New York
Times called our juror Dan Ivanka
for the Jews well we can stop right
there for just a second and note there
has never been an article called is Mike
Pence good for the Christians there's
never been an article asking whether
Rasheeda Talib is good for the Muslims
right none of this is ever asked it's
only are certain people good for the
Jews which is pretty parochial stuff and
you know is is certainly something that
folks should not really be asking an
amazing stream newspaper but beyond that
the general tenor of the article is that
because Jared Kushner and Ivanka Trump
are related to the President of the
United States and because they are
pro-israel and they are Pro Jewish this
means that they are bad for the Jews why
because liberal Jews don't like them and
one of my pet peeves in life is a bunch
of people who have no relationship with
Judaism or very little relationship with
Judaism then speaking out on behalf of
what Judaism is I have to hear from a
bunch of people who go to synagogue once
a year and then break for lunch on Yom
Kippur tell me about the nature of
Judaism I a guy who wears a yarmulke
every day of my life and prays three
times a day and eats kosher and keep
Sabbath I have to be told by a bunch of
people who care more about same-sex
marriage than they do about the State of
Israel about Jewish priorities that's
what this New York Times article is it's
really gross and here's what the article
says on election night in Beverly Hills
Jason Blum the hotshot horror movie
producer was accepting an award at the
Israeli Film Festival the polls in a
string of midterm contests were closing
and mr. Blum a vocal critic of President
Trump was talking about how much was at
stake the past two years have been hard
for all of us who charged the freedoms
we enjoy it's citizens of this country
mr. Blum said that's when the crowd of
mostly Jewish producers and power
brokers started to chant we like Trump
and his rally man stepped onto the stage
to try to pull up mr. Blum away from the
microphones as the crowd at the Saban
theater Steve Tisch cinema Center
cheered as you can see from this
auditorium it's the end of civil
discourse mr. Blum said thanks to our
president anti-semitism is on the rise
or alternatively a bunch of Jews like
President Trump because Jews who care a
lot about Jewish religious practice Jews
who care a lot about the State of Israel
Jews who care about fighting Muslim
leftist anti-semitism those are two
different types of anti-semitism those
people are not angry at President Trump
whose administration has been forceful
in its condemnation of those things as
I've said before I was a very strong
critic of President Trump when it comes
to his treatment of the alt-right I
remain so but that is not the same thing
as saying that anyone like Jared and
Ivanka who have militated against
Trump's behavior
these situations that those people are
bad for the Jews I remember these
articles from the left about Rahm
Emanuel who legitimately if anybody
could be said to be bad for the Jews
would be rahm emanuel was reported by
ron it was reported that rahm emanuel
member former chief of staff to
president obama is reported early on in
his administration that he actually went
to a jewish dinner and told jewish
donors that if they didn't pressure
israel to make concessions to the
palestinians then he would essentially
allow Iran to go nuclear
he later denied it but the people who
reported it stood by the report I didn't
remember any articles from the neuro
Times on this at the time but this
article goes on for thousands and
thousands of words about how Jared and
Ivanka are bad for the Jews not even
Trump is bad for the Jews Jared and
Ivanka are bad for the Jews dr. Jonathan
Sarna is a professor of American Jewish
history at Brandeis he says for Jews who
are deeply opposed to Donald Trump and
truly believe he's an anti-semite it's
deeply problematic he's got a Jewish
son-in-law and daughter how can that be
and the New York Times takes that on the
answer is it can be because Jordan
Ivanka are basically sellouts they're
not real Jews the real Jews are the ones
who eat LOX and like bagels and read the
Sunday edition of the New York Times
into the crossword puzzle those are
that's how we measure Jewishness
according to the New York Times
mr. Kushner and Miss Trump serve as
senior advisors in the White House at a
time when Judaism is under assault the
FBI said this week anti-semitic attacks
have been creech increased in each of
the last three years
they're unabashedly Orthodox observing
Shabbat each week walking to an orthodox
Chabad chill near their collar amma home
in washington DC dropping their children
off at a Jewish day school and hanging
mezuzahs on the doors of their West Wing
offices I love when they say at a time
when Judaism is under assault please
name a time when Judaism has not been
under assault I go wait because it turns
out Judaism has been under assault for
at least several thousand years at this
point after the Pittsburgh attack mr.
Kushner played a key role and mr. Trump
decrying the scourge of anti-semitism
mr. Kushner helped arrange the
president's visit to the Squirrel Hill
synagogue including inviting Ron Dermer
the Israeli ambassador to the United
States to accompany them there in
Pittsburgh according to the new york
times thousands march to protest what
one organizer described as the insult of
mr. Trump's visit never mind that those
protests were organized by active
opponents of President Trump who hate
Trump for a variety of reasons beyond
whatever he says about the alt-right
blaming Kushner and Ivanka for all of
this is just insane but that's of course
what the New York Times does they even
go back
an interview a guy who knew Jared back
when he was in high school with him
which is ridiculous
there's nothing roryd to kill us than
people going back and interviewing
members of people's high school classes
and so that sheds any real light on what
they are as adults I promise you if you
interviewed me about my high school
classmates have a lot of nasty thing to
say about my high school classmates most
of whom have turned into productive
citizens but you've got this guy in an
era creamer a lawyer in New York who's
on Kushner's trivia team at the Frisch
school which is an Orthodox school in
New Jersey says we as Jews are forced to
grapple with the fact that Jared and his
wife are Jewish but Jared is
participating in acts of Hillel Hashem
for folks who don't speak the Hebrew
that means desecration of God's name yes
Jared is engaged in desecration and the
New York Times prints Nez
the New York Times print this and again
I find this incredibly ironic from the
same newspaper that legitimately printed
a story about four years ago in which
they listed the Jewish population by
district of the various representatives
of the United States who did not support
the Iran ziyal they went through the
senatorial populations to figure out
which senators had the biggest Jewish
constituency and then they blamed the
Jews for those senators not supporting
the Iran deal
hey this is that newspaper and that
newspaper is now talking about what's
good for the Jews I'll tell you what's
bad for the Jews the New York Times is
bad for the Jews I'm old enough to
remember when the New York Times was was
describing photos showing Jewish police
officers in Israel defending Jews as
Jewish police officers abusing
Palestinians I'm old enough to remember
when the New York Times was was bare it
was was burying news about the Second
Intifada I'm old enough to remember when
the Times published an opinion piece
arguing that saying that Israel did not
have a right to exist was not an
anti-semitic statement as in 2013 and
the New York Times is bad for the Jews
but this is what intersectional thinking
does to you intersectional thinking does
cross over with anti-semitism in a
pretty heavy way I've discussed this on
the program before folks on the Left
don't want to acknowledge that leftist
anti-semitism crosses over with
mainstream leftist thinking in a real
material dangerous way there's a woman
who I think is is a really nice person
who has you know written about a variety
of Jewish issues over at a Jewish
newspaper called the forward and it was
bought UN gar Sargon and she and I have
have
pretty good relationship we we talk with
each other online on a fairly frequent
basis
well she tweeted out this is a good
example of this she tweeted out over the
weekend her disappointment at the fact
that Linda Sarsour who's a longtime
anti-semite
issued a statement in support of
congresswoman elect Johanna Omar who
herself is an anti-semite who supports
boycott against Israel designed to
destroy the Jewish state and by you
Unger Sargon tweeted out that she didn't
understand why Linda Sarsour would do
this she said really really really
disappointed to see this canard of dual
loyalties from Linda Sarsour Linda
Sarsour said anybody who criticized
aloha Nomar was really loyal to Israel
not loyal to the United States so as
Jews who are who are Jews first those
evil Jews and by you Unger Sargon who is
on the left and kind of likes the
women's March she said I don't know if
she's subtweeting my piece but I'm
pretty upset by this what a betrayal of
the intersectional ideal here is the
thing the intersectional ideal is in and
of itself crossing over with
anti-semitism because the intersectional
ideal is built on the idea that there
are hierarchies of power and these
hierarchies of power decide how exactly
all of life works all of life is built
around hierarchies of power if it were
not for these hierarchies of power life
would be utopia but thanks to the
capitalistic freedom based system of the
West this has created evil hierarchies
of power and the intersectional
coalition are groups of people who have
been victimized by these hierarchies of
power black folks and gay folks and
Hispanic folks and women and maybe Jews
the reason I say maybe Jews is because
it turns out that in Western society and
free societies Jews tend to do pretty
well why did use tend to do pretty well
in free societies well a couple of
reasons one Jews actually values very
very highly education this has been true
since the inception of the Jewish people
when studying Torah was it was an
important thing Jews have always been
over educated as compared to the general
population in the areas where they exist
and that has an impact on earnings
beyond that Jews also tend to be pretty
vocal about politics because it's
because they are versed in politics in
ways that other populations are not in
sometimes what that means is that the
left believes that Jews are at the top
of the intersectional hierarchy there
are people who have benefited from the
hierarchy and that means that when Jews
are attacked by anti-semites they sorta
a little bit deserve it because it
depends on the situation but if they're
being attacked by somebody lower on the
intersectional hierarchy if for example
a black pastor like Louis Farrakhan a
black a black leader like Louis
Farrakhan attacks Jews that's okay it's
not anti-semitism
that's just intersectionality in action
it's somebody from a lower ranking
member of an intersectional hierarchy
group attacking somebody on top and
that's okay because in intersectionality
if you rank lower on the intersectional
hierarchy if you are if you are a member
of a group that has been more victimized
you can attack anybody from another
group that is on top of you in the
intersectional hierarchy Jews are near
the top so anti-semitism crosses over
with the conspiracy theory that is that
it that is into intersectionality which
is a conspiracy theory on its own
crosses over with the conspiracy theory
of anti-semitism which suggests that
Jews are in control of the levers of
world power so it is not a surprise to
see the New York Times which has
routinely aided and abetted the attacks
on Jews in Israel which admitted two
weeks ago that they don't report on
attacks on Jews in New York City when
those attacks on Jews don't come from
white supremacists they admitted that in
the paper we talked about it that New
York Times is now talking about Jordan
Ivanka being the true victimizers and
foreigners of anti-semitism not a shock
but still particularly gross
I wanna get to more on intersectionality
and how it's making everybody insane in
just a second but first let's talk about
drinking okay I know this all makes you
want to take a drink right I mean it
makes me want to take a drink well if
you want to take a drink and that drink
should taste good
you're right you'd like a wine that
actually matches up with your palate
well the best way to do that is by going
over to link and we are approaching the
time of the season when it's time to
relax a little bit and why not relax
with a nice bottle of linked wine winc
it's a great resource
it makes enjoying downtime a lot easier
wink makes it easy to discover great
wine why because they are wine experts
selected wines match to your taste
personalized for you shipped directly to
your door starting just 13 bucks a
bottle there's nothing like coming home
to a bottle of delicious wink wine
selected just for you it is the best day
of your month with a lot of folks in the
office or wink subscribers which is why
productivity has gone down but enjoyment
has gone up just check out links palate
profile quiz and then you answer simple
questions that your average store clerk
wouldn't translate into a recommendation
like how do you take your coffee how do
you feel about blueberries and then wink
sends wines curated to your tastes the
more wines you rate the more
personalized or monthly selections it's
like Netflix for wine go check it out
right now discover a great wine today go
to try wink comm slash Ben you'll get 20
bucks off your first
that's t ry winc comm slash pen for $20
off again tri wink comm slash Ben go
check it out right now T ry winc calm
and get $20 off when you use that promo
code Ben tri wink comm slash Ben alright
so intersectionality allows the left to
be as anti-semitic as it wants to be and
then claim that they are just standing
for the intersectional ideal it also
allows them to defend some of the
dumbest stuff on the planet in the
dumbest possible way so there's an
article in Rolling Stone you know the
Rolling Stone obviously known for its
great journalism such as when they
proclaimed that her frat was responsible
for the gang rape of a woman who was
lying the entire time Rolling Stone has
another great piece of journalism today
this is from Ariana egg nari the name of
the piece meet the woman bringing social
justice to astrology I am not kidding
you is an actual article because it
turns out that intersectionality can
explain away bad science very exciting
stuff
Channy nicholas doesn't care for the
hulking alex cats painting depicting a
trio of suited white men hanging behind
the front desk of the Langham Hotel in
New York it reminds her of the
patriarchy she tells me one rainy
starless night in February as we take
the elevator up to her to a hotel suite
and sit on the couch while wrapping up a
conversation about privilege gender
equality and the zodiac when Nicholas
has become popular on Instagram is a
kind of social justice astrologer
notices a different art piece hovering
behind her this one she likes the
painting titled Mona portrays a woman
who shares a striking resemblance to
nicholas dark hair with tight curls
sharp brown eyes a strong jawline she
compares it to the painting in the lobby
the hotel staff must have known not to
put me in a room with a bunch of weird
guys on the wall she says I'm basically
an angry feminist who just happens to be
into astrology and healing she's going a
little strong on he just happens to be
into angry feminists very often are into
astrology and healing she says Nicolas
is transforming horoscopes from
generalizations about finding true love
and stumbling into financial good
fortune she pointed calls to action with
a left-leaning social justice agenda
there's pretty good evidence that
intersectionality can it's basically
like a Shamir you can kind of schmear it
over anything on the bagel and it just
covers it up you take a little bit of
intersectionality and you spackle the
wall with it and it covers any blemish
on the wall including astrology so now
astrology is good
if it backs social justice so people who
literally think that the stars are going
to decide whether they meet their
boyfriend today those people are cool so
long as they are into social justice I
love this I have to read you more of
this article because it does demonstrate
how the left has lost its mind on a
variety of issues so Nicolas 42 is
transport is transforming horoscopes
from generalizations into a left-leaning
social justice agenda based in Los
Angeles has more than a hundred thousand
followers on Instagram and a blog with
as many as 1 million monthly readers hmm
ok just to point out the numbers on that
a blog with as many as 1 million monthly
readers The Daily wire last month had
over a hundred and forty million
pageviews
she was activism into the majority of
her writing appealing to a generation
particularly interested in issues like
racism sexism and gun control Nicolas
used last November's mercury retrograde
to urge her followers to contact the FCC
prior to its vote on net neutrality she
wrote about the new moon in Scorpio
representing the need to heal during the
initial wave of sexual assault
accusations in Hollywood she's posted
about daca and the border wall and has
even been promoting an online tool
called free forum which was started by
her wife Sonia passing to help victims
of domestic violence understand how to
pursue financial compensation in fact
last October Nicolas raised $40,000 from
her free forum by offering her followers
a chance to win one of five free
astrology readings so it's okay to be a
con woman that's totally fine it's okay
to be a complete con woman so long as
you back social justice but don't worry
all of the Christians who believe in
Jesus those are the crazy people all the
Christians who believe that Jesus makes
her life better all the Jews who believe
the Bible makes her life better those
are the crazy theocrats not the people
who think that the stars have something
to say about the latest gender studies
course at UCLA yeah that's that's all
great that's not even the best example
of intersectional thinking making people
totally insane the best example today
comes from something called Boston
review a political and literary forum
this is a review of the movie sorry to
bother you and the review is by a human
named Robin DG Kelly hey this is some of
my favorite stuff ever it is so good
okay so the article is all
about how this how this movie is is
really great at at destroying the
patriarchy and all the rest
the explanation is about the director of
the of the movie whose name is Raymond
boots Riley who's director of sorry to
bother you and this is a quote for Riley
life is not inherently absurd instead
its absurdities are produced by
capitalism racism and patriarchy the
point of dialectical analysis is not to
find the meaning of life but to reveal
the fundamental antagonisms in the
material world for Riley as for Marx
only by remoulding the world can we
begin to resolve its philosophical
contradictions sorry to bother you
chooses revolution over the lone Camus
Sein rebel suggesting that our survival
as a species and as a planet depends on
the overthrow of capitalism the
redistribution of wealth and the
complete reordering of society based on
collective needs as long as the state
continues to employ brutal force to
suppress popular opposition
revolutionary violence will remain a
legitimate tactic okay I just want to
point out this is some crazy Schmidt and
this is some crazy stuff is this some
crazy stuff life is not inherently
absurd instead its absurdities are
produced by capitalism racism and
patriarchy so if it were not for you
know people freely exchanging goods and
services at a point of their choosing
and the price of their choosing then
there would be no absurdity to life if
it were not for the fact that men and
women are different there would be no
absurdity to life you get the feeling
from a lot of the the intersectional
coalition that's screaming at the moon
is one of the things that they love the
most which may be why they like
astrology apparently but screaming at
the moon it's not actually a solution
for your life it's funny you know
there's a lot of crossover between folks
who listen to this show and people who
are fans of Jordan Peterson and I've
been asked why before and the reason is
because an enormous amount of what we
talk about here on the show is about the
idea that life is not fair and my
daughter who is four-and-a-half she the
other day she picked up from somewhere
this phrase not fair it makes me crazy
and I've said to her when she says not
fair I've said to her work harder
because that's the real world the real
world is in a free society there is
going to be unfairness in a free society
not everything is distributed the way
that you want it to be and if for fruit
in a freeze
society not every outcome is equal that
does not mean that you're relieved of
the responsibility to be a good human
being or that you have the right to
violate somebody else's rights because
things are not fair in fact to be exact
this morning my daughter said to me not
fair and I said to her you know what
happens to people in this house who say
not fair you know what happens
the not fair bird comes it's a giant
bird it comes from the sky it picks you
up and it takes you to an island filled
with your brother's poop and then it
drops you on that island
my daughter is smart so she laughed and
and that was the end of not fair so we
have not done not fair we'll see how
long that lasts
but before we get to more intersectional
stupidity plus I want to get to I want
to get to Democrats challenging
elections and proclaiming that elections
are no longer fair very interesting to
watch as the left decides that it's very
bad to challenge elections in which
Democrats win very good to challenge
elections in which Republicans win first
let's talk about your sleep quality so
you've thought about your mattress
you've thought about your bed frame
you've thought about your futon and but
yeah what you haven't thought about is
your sheets okay the reality is that the
sheets that you are sleeping on are
probably garbage you probably went over
to the local Bed Bath and Beyond you
picked up whatever had the highest
thread count and you didn't actually
know anything about it so you picked up
what in essence turned out to be a
plastic tarp and they've been sleeping
on that for two years and you're
uncomfortable and you're sweating in the
night you don't know why well the reason
is because you're not using bowl and
branch you need Bowl and branch they
make bedding it and blankets made from
pure 100% organic cotton which means
they start out super soft and they get
even softer over time you buy directly
from them so you're essentially paying
wholesale prices luxury sheets can cost
up to a thousand dollars in the store
but when branch sheets are only a couple
of hundred bucks everybody who tries
Boleyn branch sheets loves them which is
why three u.s. presidents sleep on bull
and branch eats shipping is free you can
try them for 30 nights if you don't love
them send them back for a refund but
you're not gonna want to do any of that
but it's risk-free to get you started
right now my listeners get 50 bucks off
your first set of sheets at bull and
branch calm promo code Ben that's bull
and branch comp remote code Ben and we
use that promo code Ben you get 50 bucks
off your first set of sheets Bo LL and
branch calm promo code Ben well as I say
the intersectional theory allows people
to ignore bad behavior and this is the
point that I was making to my daughter
intersectional therapy not fair theory
of the world allows people to proclaim
that unfairness is a solution to you
being a bad person and saying
things and you're not getting your way
that must all be about racism sexism
bigotry and homophobia and this leads to
some pretty absurd results so for
example there's an article in the Miami
Herald so there's a woman who's a
manager and she refused to serve five
black men in this Chipotle she asked
them to prove they had the money to pay
for their meals before placing their
orders and then they fired this woman
they suggested that this woman had
treated the customers wrongly the
footage would had been retweeted more
than 52,000 times it showed the Chipotle
employees in st. Paul Minnesota
moving on serving white woman without
asking her to show proof of income
Chipotle said this is not how we treat
our customers or committed to treating
everyone equally in with respect the
manager has been terminated and we are
retraining everyone at the restaurant to
ensure something like this doesn't
happen again well then it turns out that
that's not the whole story shock of
shocks that is not the whole story at
all here is the updated story Chipotle
is rethinking its initial decision of
firing one of its managers after a video
posted Friday on Twitter showed
employees refusing to serve five black
men and asking them to prove they had
the money to pay for their meals quote
our actions were based on the facts
known to us immediately after the
incident said the company we now have
additional information which needs to be
investigated further we want to do the
right thing so after further
investigation we'll retrain and rehire
if the facts warrant it what exactly
changed well it turns out it turns out
that the men who went in there to eat
had a long a long history on Twitter of
bragging about dining and dashing eating
without paying Hey hours after the video
went viral Twitter users began to scour
this guy's Twitter page and they posted
photos of him his previous tweets here's
what he wrote in 2015 quote dine and
dash is forever interesting March 27
guys we're borrowing food that's it and
if the lady tries to stop you at the
door don't hesitate to truck the bleep
out of that another post guys and
they're a bunch of these he said we're
not doing a time and - we're just
borrowing the food that's all so it
turns out the manager knew these people
and the manager wanted them to pay for
their food but because of the
intersectional ideal we were supposed to
ignore all of the other facts at least
until further notice and then it turns
out when the facts come out oops oops
oops so instead of just asking the
question beforehand like mate when they
just ask
right I could've just said to the
manager why did you do that and she
would have said oh because these guys
have been known to eat the food and
leave without paying it's just it's an
amazing thing but the assumption on the
left is that if they don't get their way
then this is because someone has
violated the the intersectional ideal
Kirsten powers is now playing this game
Kirsten used to be a much more rational
human when it came to politics no longer
here she is on CNN claiming that white
women are violating their own identities
as white women by voting for President
Trump and they'll say well I'm not
racist I just voted for him because you
know I I i didn't like Hillary Clinton
and I just want to say that that's not
that doesn't make you not racist it
actually makes you racist if you support
somebody who does racist things that
makes you racist so I just want to
establish that so it makes you racist
not to support a white woman as a white
woman it makes you racist because again
intersectionality the this sort of this
sort of idea that unfairness can always
be justified by reference to the
patriarchy and to the hierarchies of
power
he's quite disgusting and again at least
it's a pretty horrible results a
horrible result that was nearly that was
just averted I happened last week when
Christopher CJ procopio very nearly
spent the rest of his life in prison
after being accused of assault by his
ex-girlfriend is according to ash scow
over at Daily wire and woman who despite
obviously reporting a false crime has
still not been named or charged claimed
that procopio broke into her house
attacked with a box cutter slashing an X
into her chest
based on her story and the cleanly
sliced X on her chest procopio was
arrested the 21 year old man then told
kvu e news he was confused
when he was arrested in September 2017
at the lumber yard where he worked he
couldn't remember when he last spoke to
the woman whom he had dated earlier in
high school I had no idea why everything
was happening and I was lost he was then
taken to jail he faced ninety nine years
in prison he had to pay a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars bond and then it
turns out that her son the mother of the
son knew he wasn't even in town that
night he was with his mom in Northwest
Austin Texas hotel sixty-five miles
where the alleged attack happened so
here's the question why exactly has this
woman not been charged she has not been
charged as of yet and yet we are
supposed to and we were supposed to
pretend that that's okay that she has
not been charged as of yet
due process exists because we don't
believe that we can simply adjudicate
the results of elections or crimes or
injustice 'as by reference to the
identities of the players this is why I
do process exists this is why honesty
and intellectual honesty exist this is
why we ought to not be looking at the
identities of the people we disagree
with you got to be looking at the ideas
of the people who disagree with whether
we're talking about Jared and Ivanka
Kushner or whether we are talking about
the this or were there talking about
astrology looking at the issues and
looking at the logic and looking at the
reason as opposed to looking at the
identity of the player is a better way
to reach a reasonable logical decent
conclusion than by simply assuming that
we can look at people's identity and
then determine the quality of their of
their speech or the quality of their
logic on the basis of that identity I
mean while the left is continuing to
push the idea that the Republicans have
never won a decent selection that every
Republican elections have ever won has
been stolen by there's a pull out today
or yesterday showing that an enormous
number of Democrats think that Russia
actively tampered with election balance
according to an economist YouGov poll
was the poll was done a couple of weeks
ago sixty-seven percent of Democrats
believe it is definitely true or
probably true that Russia tampered with
vote tallies in order to get Donald
Trump elected two thirds of Democrats
believe that the Russians actively hacks
the election tampered with vote tallies
and yet we're told that only President
Trump is undermining electoral
institutions bill Nelson in Florida he
came out over the weekend he said that
he lost because of voter suppression
there is no evidence of voter
suppression no one is being stopped from
going to the polls for illegal reasons
nobody is being told that they cannot
vote nobody who is trying to legally
vote is being stopped at the polls this
is nonsense it's just garbage here is
Bill Nelson though promoting the idea
that if he loses it was because of voter
suppression we must end all forms of
voter suppression make it easier for
Americans to vote and honor the ideal
that we are governed by the majority and
not the minority rule this is just lying
garbage and it's not just Bill Nelson
it's Stacey Abrams as well she conceded
that she lost the election the other
night but she said that she didn't
legitimately lose the election it was
stolen from her
even though she lost by at last check
53,000 votes
something like that here in any case is
Stacey Abrams is he the legitimate
governor-elect of Georgia he is the
person who won an adequate number of
votes but that's not I'm the governor
with all with all due respect and I
respect where you're coming from and I
respect the the issues that you're
raising you're not answering the
question do you think you're not using
the word legitimate is he the legitimate
governor-elect of Georgia he is the
legal governor of Georgia okay he's the
legal issue she won't say he is
legitimate governor elect is this
dangerous can we acknowledge that this
is dangerous stuff that it undermines
electoral integrity when Democrats do
this kind of stuff I'm going to show you
in one second how much of a why this is
that said that Brian Kemp in Georgia
sold the election again the idea in in
Florida that Republicans stole the
election is absurd Broward County deputy
Brenda Snipes the election official over
there she actually resigned over the
weekend because she's so incompetent
she's a Democrat I'm gonna explain a
little bit more about what's going on
with these elections plus president
Trump had himself a weekend we'll
discuss that in just a second first
let's talk about the watch on your risk
is a good-looking does it look like this
is it nice is it spare is it clean does
it tell you the time well if not you
should be checking out movement because
movement watches are all about looking
good while keeping it simple they don't
tell you how many steps you've taken
they'll blow up your risk with text
messages they're not overly intrusive on
life instead they tell you the time and
they look classy while doing it they've
sold almost two million washes worldwide
by bringing quality designs at great
prices but the holiday season coming
gifting is very easy with movements
versatile line of watches glasses and
accessories they also make sunglasses
that are really nice that bracelets too
for ladies if all sorts of good stuff
movement watches start at just 95 bucks
you're looking at four to five hundred
bucks for the same quality from
traditional brands clean design
minimal quality products if you need
help giving the perfect gift the season
you don't where to start and don't know
where to start the guys over at movement
they have your back and they did all the
hard work so you wouldn't have to what
so you wouldn't have to buy curating
their favorite styles into awesome gift
boxes and packages get 25% off today
during movements Black Friday Cyber
Monday sale with free shipping and free
returns by going to MVM t.com slash
appear again 25% off today when you go
to MVM t-dot-com slash up here we'll go
join the movement right now movement has
new styles all the time on their site
it's a lot of fun go check it out MVM
t.com slash appear when you use that
slash
hero again you got 25% off today during
their Black Friday Cyber Monday sale I
have movement watch my wife has a
movement watch my father has a movement
watch my mother has a movement watch
like legitimately every member of my
family has a movement watch I have to
get one for my kids when they get old
enough because they really are nice go
check them out right now MVM t.com /
shapiro for that special deal alright
also before we go any further you're
gonna have to go subscribe when you do
you get the rest of the show live the
rest of Clavin show live Rustom Noel's
show live in it is almost time for our
next episode of the conversation on
Tuesday November 20th 5:30 p.m. Eastern
2:30 p.m. Pacific all of your questions
will be answered by Daily wires own
Michael Knowles I have no idea why you
would think that Michael Knowles has
answers to any of your questions but if
you're one of these illusional people
you can pay him money to get those
answers and Alicia crafts will be there
to host it and keep Knowles in line
which means that you will have to
actually physically staplegun him to the
wall which is why you should pay because
I mean that's worth money this month's
episode will stream live on Daily wires
YouTube and Facebook pages it's free for
everybody to watch only subscribers can
ask the questions to ask questions as a
subscriber log in to our website daily
wire comm head over to the conversation
page to watch the live stream after that
just start typing into the daily wired
chat box where Michael will answer
questions as they come in for an entire
hour again subscribe get your questions
answered by the execrable michael moles
on Tuesday November 28th 5:30 p.m.
Eastern 2:30 p.m. Pacific
join the conversation also we have all
sorts of goodies that you get when you
become an annual subscriber that is $99
a year and you get this the leftist
here's how to raquel temblor view it
look on it with envy and wonder it is
spectacular and you can have that with
your annual subscription at $99 a year
as opposed to $9.99 monthly I know $9.99
sounds like it's less money than $99 but
$99 a year is cheaper than $9.99 monthly
check my math you'll find that it's true
get all of those things and subscribe at
YouTube or iTunes leave us a review we
really appreciate it we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast in
the nation
[Music]
so stacy abrams bill nelson lying about
these election results democrats across
the country suggesting voter suppression
has taken place which is just nonsense
particularly when they say it's directed
at the minority community in fact is
black folks in the united states have
been increasing their voter share and i
believe every election cycle so this
idea that they are they're somehow being
barred from the polls in outsized
numbers is just nonsense Barack Obama
won Ohio in 2008 and 2012 because black
folks were over-represented at the polls
which means that they were showing up in
numbers bigger than their actual
percentage of the population some of the
folks who are telling lies like this
there's a guy named Ari Berman who
tweeted out that Brian Kemp who's the
new governor-elect of Georgia had purged
1.5 million votes and then he put fifty
three thousand registrations on hold and
that there were four and a half hour
lines 214 polling places closed
Dems falsely accused of cyber crimes
candidate overseeing own election this
election was stolen
except that is a lie the idea that 1.5
million votes were purged is not true
that is the number of voters who have
been removed from the rolls since 2012
because some of them are dead many of
them committed felonies a lot of them
moved the overwhelming majority of the
rest were moved because Georgia has they
use it or lose it law which was passed
in 1997 by a Democratic legislature and
a Democratic governor in Georgia is by
AG conservative over a Twitter who's
exactly correct similar laws have been
upheld by the Supreme Court it requires
the rules to be updated by removing
voters that have not voted for some time
and don't respond to contact from the
state the reason there is a large spike
in 2017 is because in 2015
state officials did not actually do what
they were supposed to do how about
53,000 registrations on hold these
registrations were labeled pending but
that occurred because there was some
discrepancy between their registration
and their file that is their fault they
were not actually updating their file
you have to update your file and you
move for example four and a half hour
lines there are long lines at some
polling locations because this happens
on Election Day have you never been to a
poll depends where I guess you vote but
the fact is that long lines on Election
Day are an actual thing and most places
did have relatively short waiting times
there's one polling location in one
County that had machine malfunctions
which led to the 4.5 hour wait how about
214 polling places close this is a bunch
of nonsense as well those places were
consolidated with other low
to save money those decisions were made
by local county officials if you think
Brian Kemp oversaw the shuttering of
locations that is just a lie so all of
this is not true but Democrats continue
to proclaim every time they lose an
election
it's about voter suppression and then
they wonder why the country is
fragmenting you know when Barack Obama
was elected I didn't like him I thought
he's a bad president and I said that I
said so many many times over an entire
book on it hey but Barack Obama was
legitimately elected he was my president
because he was legitimately elected Bill
Clinton was legitimately elected and was
therefore my president there are lots of
senators who are legitimately elected
from California Kamala Harris is my
senator she's a terrible senator I don't
like her but she was legitimately
elected Democrats however cannot say
that Trump is their president they
cannot say that george w bush was their
president they cannot say that Brian
Kemp is their governor of Georgia they
can't say that Ron DeSantis he's the
governor of Florida or that Rick Scott
is legitimately the governor of Florida
and you're talking to me about to
nihilism on the right you're talking to
me about the right refusing to
acknowledge reality just crazy if you
want to talk about actual real
corruption why don't we turn instead to
New York City this is story by Greg
Smith over at the New York Daily News
the city's top watchdog charged Monday
that Mayor Bill de Blasio fired him in
part to put the brakes on pending probes
describing the mayor as vindictive and
at times unhinged in his fury at the
Department of Investigation weird that
this will not receive the same national
coverage that President Trump and the
Muller investigation have despite the
fact there is no evidence that Trump has
actually attempted to interfere with the
model investigation here you have the
person running the investigation into
Bill de Blasio accusing Bill de Blasio
of actively interfering in the
investigation you're not going to see
this reported outside of a couple of
sources it's certainly not going to be
running blanket coverage on CNN the way
that it would be if it were a Republican
DOI Commissioner mark Peters filed a
letter to the City Council firing back
at Bill de Blasio and his stated reason
for terminating Peters which the mayor
attributed to a report and found Peters
had exceeded his authority in trying to
fold an independent schools investigator
into the Department of investigations on
several occasions the mayor and his most
senior staff have expressed visible
anger at me over certain DOI
investigations
he wrote they've requested that I not
issue certain reports and want an
inclined to do so they took actions to
demonstrate their anger in ways that
were clearly designed to be intimidating
Peters described
late night screaming phone call from the
mayor and revealed that the mayor's
office had tried to get him to kill a
November 2017 report that revealed how
then NY CH a and the Mets Housing
Authority chairwoman Shola a Latoya had
falsely claimed that the authority was
performing required lead paint expect
inspections when she knew they were not
so he tried to kill a report suggesting
that the city was not doing all it could
to protect children from lead paint bill
de blasio even so had governmental
corruption
this is governmental corruption not
Brian Kemp in Georgia now Ron de santis
and Rick Scott in Florida this is what
you call legitimate corruption the mayor
trying to shut down an investigation
into other Democratic members of his
administration because he doesn't care
if bad things happen to kids because of
lead paint according to this
investigator this pressure argues Peters
suggested a desire to present to prevent
diy's independence going forward he said
I worry that the mayor's actions in this
regard will cause lasting damage to do
eyes independence it will surely cause
any successor to think twice before
conducting the type of vital systemic
investigations into agencies bill de
blasio of course immensely popular with
the far left even though he's done a
garbage job as the actual mayor of New
York City well with the Democrats is
skewing radical and there's no question
that they are and this does raise the
question why can't Republicans take
advantage with Democrats claiming that
elections are illegitimate
but Democrats falling into the
intersectional cycle of claiming that
every loss is the result of racism and
bigotry
well Democrats trying to malign people
who disagree with them as members of an
intersectional hierarchy victimizing
other folks
why can't Republicans take advantage one
of the Republicans can't take advantage
is because when the other side is making
a mistake there's a basic role politics
when the other side is making a mistake
don't interrupt them when somebody's in
the middle of making a mistake in
politics you let them go you give them
enough rope to hang themselves
president Trump however is a master at
interrupting the bad news on the other
side he did it an interview over the
weekend it was not good for the
president he did it with Chris Wallace
on Fox News and it was he made a series
of headlines that allow the the press to
obscure with him bloviating the fact
that they're melting the Democrats are
melting down in a variety of ways so
here's president trans president Trump
was talking with Chris Wallace and he
was asked why he doesn't act more
moderate in terms of his rhetoric
I think if I was a you know more
modified more moderate in that sense I
don't think I would have done half of
the things that I was able to get
completed okay that is not true
he had a Republican Congress you had
Republican Senate if the President had
not been creating obstacles for his own
Congress that probably would have been
better and then he decided to generate
more headlines he's decided he was going
to a he's appointed a new Attorney
General for the moment the acting
Attorney General Matt Whittaker well
Matt Whittaker is it's questionable as
to whether the appointment itself was
legal because Whittaker was never
approved by the Senate that's an open
question but he was asked whether he
would tell Whittaker to lay off Robert
Muller and here was what President Trump
had to say about that look he it's gonna
be up to him I think he's very well
aware politically I think he's astute
politically he's a very smart person a
very respected person he's going to do
what's right
I really believe he's going to do what's
right but you won't overrule him if he
decides to curtail I would not get
involved okay it what he really should
be saying there is I've seen no
indicator that Matt Whittaker intends to
shut down them all our investigation
that'd be the smart political answer
instead it looks like he's allowing the
appointment of Whittaker to go forward
so Whittaker can do something about
Muller even though I don't actually
think that is what's happening here the
biggest headline that came out over the
weekend there are two big headlines
coming out over the weekend both of them
had to do again with President Trump his
sort of personality quirks to put it in
the nicest possible fashion he attacked
Admiral McRaven so Admiral McRaven
you'll recall William McRaven was the
guy who was in charge of the kill of
Osama bin Laden he was the Navy SEAL
Admiral and McRaven is in fact
left-leaning on a number of policies the
reason that you know this is cuz people
were talking about him for the
Democratic nomination just a few months
back right now he's currently the head
the gene I believe of University of
Texas at Austin or the president of
University of Texas at Austin he is
retiring however but bill McRaven wrote
a piece a few months back in which he
ripped into President Trump for his lack
of decorum President Trump decided to
rip back into McRaven in a way that is
really unnecessary frankly he's a Navy
SEAL it is nice if we got Osama bin
Laden a lot sooner than that wouldn't it
have been nice you know living think of
this living in Pakistan beautifully in
Pakistan
and what I guess they considered a nice
mansion I don't know I've seen nicer but
living in Pakistan right next to the
military academy everybody in Pakistan
knew he was there and we give Pakistan
1.3 billion dollars a year and they
don't tell him what does that have to do
the bill McRaven exactly like bill
McRaven was sitting on the killer bin
Laden in reality was done it was Barack
Obama who sat on the killer bin Laden
over like a full 72 hour weekend right
he said that he had to think about it
but McRaven as soon as he got the order
went in and took care of business this
of course led McRaven to fire back none
of this is good for the President as a
news cycle he said I admire presidents
who uphold the dignity of the office
because Trump said that he was a Hillary
Clinton backer he said I did not back
Hillary Clinton or anyone else I'm a fan
of President Obama and President George
W Bush both of whom I worked for I
admire all presidents regardless of
their political party I'll pull the
dignity of the office and who used that
office to bring the nation together in
challenging times and then he said he
stood by his comments that the
president's attack on the media is the
greatest threat to democracy in my
lifetime now that of course is a wild
overstatement that trumps threats attack
on the media is the greatest threat to
democracy in his lifetime come on come
on I mean it's just sheer nonsense but
is it good for President Trump that he
feels the necessity to jump on every
public relations hand grenade with both
feet probably not and that didn't stop
him over the weekend from going off on
Adam Schiff so Adam Schiff is the
Congress person out here in California
who is on CNN all the time talking about
Russia without a lot of evidence to
support him President Trump decided that
he would go after him he said so funny
to see little Adam
and then TT say he misspelled shifts
name which is s CH iff s CH I ATT
talking about the fact that acting
Attorney General Matt Whittaker was not
approved by the Senate but not
mentioning the fact of Bob Muller who
was highly conflicted was not approved
by the Senate Bob Muller was appointed
by members of his own Department of
Justice and did not assume his position
but put that aside he isn't like a good
look for the president to be attacking
members of Congress as Adam bleep
probably not is this gonna win back the
suburbs no again key rule politics when
your opponents are making a mistake
don't interrupt them both sides however
seem to
be saying to the other hold my beer and
that is that is a bad strategy for
electoral politics generally okay time
for some things I like and then some
things that I hate some things I like I
pledged last week that we would do a
little bit of William Goldman since
William Goldman passed away last week
William Goldman's best movie is the
Princess Bride and the Princess Bride is
just a delight I'm sure everyone in the
audience is already seen The Princess
Bride if you have not it is just a
fantastic clever witty movie the only
problem with the Princess Bride is the
score is just terrible
I at some point I really wish that
somebody would go back and get rid of
the synthesizer because the synthesizer
is is awful but the rest of the movie is
great Mandy Patinkin is fantastic Andre
the Giant is great Carrie eul's is
terrific
and and of course Robin Wright Penn is
that's her name correct yes she's
terrific in the movie as well the whole
movie is just delightful and of course
very young Fred Savage making an
appearance I here's a little bit of the
of the trailer it was a time when life
didn't seem so complicated I'm killing
myself once we reach the honeymoon suite
a courtly age
of gentle conversation I will always
come for you how can you be sure this is
true love
oh is this a kissing book no actually
there was a lot of treachery the preview
I loved the 80s previews with everybody
in the background first but the movie
itself is so entertaining and so
glorious and I'm looking forward to the
point where my kids are old enough to
watch it also of course while with Sean
the best thing in the movie right doing
the the well is Sean in the Battle of
what's inconceivable so if you haven't
checked out the movie I don't know where
you've been living like under a rock or
what but it's it's pretty spectacular
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate all righty so this is an amazing
controversy a 66 year old substitute
teacher is according to law and crime
has been told not to return to Parkway
south high school after he thanked
students who participated in the
recitation of the Pledge of Allegiance
interestingly the school nickname is the
Patriots here is the teacher
Jim freaking explaining the situation
yeah announcer says please rise for the
Pledge of Allegiance right come on let's
go kids get up in this particular case
twenty four kids in class twenty two got
up you know so I say thank you very much
all of you that participated I
appreciate that
and I'm sure all those families that
lost loved ones so that we could have
the freedoms that we have today would
appreciate that too and that's what I
said
superintendent dr. Keith Marty now says
the students who did not stand were
humiliated and teased by the others are
you done okay so he has been invited to
not return to teaching the powerplay
superintendent had firkin had a pattern
of inappropriate conduct he said that it
was worth noting that firkins comments
caused disruption during class by
praising certain students for standing
the students who made the decision not
to stand were humiliated and then teased
class environment did not cultivate an
atmosphere of learning and acceptance of
the views and values of others well I
wasn't aware that it was necessary to
cultivate a view that standing for the
Pledge of Allegiance was a matter of
moral neutrality I wasn't aware that
that was a necessary thing to cultivate
in a classroom
honestly like I wouldn't want anybody
bullying anybody else in a classroom and
I'm for diversity of viewpoint but it
seems to me not inappropriate for the
teacher to thank people for standing to
the for the Pledge of Allegiance in
that it has meaning for a lot of folks
who have served our nation in the
military like that that is obviously
true and if you can't take the heat get
out of the kitchen if you're if you
don't want to be criticized for taking a
politically a politically volatile
action then don't take the politically
volatile action is one of this is one of
my pet peeves is a bunch of people put
themselves sort of in politically
volatile situations and then they're
like oh man how dare you how dare you
get mad when I do that I'm seeing some
of that today with Alexandre Ocasio
Cortez so Alexander Ocasio Cortez is
being criticized today because there's a
clip of her going around in which she
defines the three branches of government
as the Congress the Senate and the
presidency which of course are not the
three branches of government and then
she tries again and says the three
branches of the legislature they're of
course - and people are mocking her for
that and folks I left why why are you
attacking Alexandria Ocasio Cortez why
are you commenting on Alexandria Ocasio
Cortes it's like guys you made her a
celebrity you decided to choose the face
of your movement and then when we
comment on it you get all mad about it
that's not how this works
the same thing with Rashida to Leia
bandit on Omar people like Glinda stars
who are saying well they get to speak to
men right they get to speak their mind I
can say they're anti-semites well a lot
of people can say lots of things it's a
free country
this idea that you are automatically
shielded from criticism when you do
something that is objectively and
verifiably offensive is beyond me I
don't understand it at all speaking of
people who are ridiculous Ben Rhodes
who's in instantly I don't know why
anyone takes this guy seriously he's the
former deputy national security advisor
whose previous experience before joining
the Obama administration was writing
unpublished crappy short stories in his
New York in his Brooklyn apartment he
now says House Democrats should
investigate whether the White House knew
that Saudi prince Crown Prince Mohammed
bin Salman was responsible for the
murder of Washington Post writer Jamal
khashoggi and then lied about it and he
said why is the White House covering up
for the Saudi murder of a dissident in a
third country here is he here's Ben
Rhodes I will explain why this is so
absurd I think what's very important
here and one of the things I want to
know about is what did Trump know and
when did he know it because the u.s.
intelligence committee without getting
into too much detail obviously shadi
riba is something that they follow very
closely and so the idea that something
like this would happen without our
intelligence agencies knowing something
about what happened I always
was very unlikely okay this is this is
absurd to hear from from Ben Rhodes
about this Ben Rhodes legitimately
covered up the Iranian murder of
American soldiers so that he could hand
them millions and millions of dollars in
cash on pallets Ben Rhodes is one of the
great liars
in the history of American foreign
policy and he's being held up as a
champion of truth and decency yes I'd
like to hear more on what the American
government knew about Jamal khashoggi
but you know what I'm much more
concerned about I'm much more concerned
about the forwarding of the Iranian
mullahs at the expense of the entire
Middle East which is exactly what the
Obama administration did with Ben Rhodes
acting as the head of the Iranian PR
apparatus okay well we will be back here
tomorrow with all of the latest i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing